well ladies and gentlemen uh California
Senator Dianne Feinstein at 89 years old
will not seek re-election in 2024 this
clears the path for a hotly contested
Democratic Primary in that state
involving Adam Schiff Katie Porter and
Barbara Lee as well as others who have
already declared that they are indeed
running we have been wondering for some
time is Dianne Feinstein going to retire
now there are sort of two stories here
first there is the story as CNBC writes
about Feinstein being the oldest sitting
U.S senator and the longest serving
Senator and a growing appetite among
Democrats in various parts of the
country for the next generation of
leaders now what's interesting is the
next Generation after Dianne Feinstein
is still people who are in their 60s so
like two generations later maybe you
know you understand what I'm saying so
there's the general desire there
the second part and we want to be
respectful when we talk about this is
specifically about Dianne Feinstein and
her cognitive State as for years now
there have been growing concerns about
what is happening with Dianne Feinstein
as she is close to 90 years old pretty
widespread reports of her very quickly
forgetting that she has met people when
she's going through her normal course of
being a senator we have seen a sort of
confused Dianne Feinstein during Senate
hearings during which she will read a
question off of a piece of paper that
she doesn't fully seem to understand and
then she will immediately read the same
question again not realizing that she
already asked that one so it's not
something we laugh at it's it's a sad
situation more than anything but it is
also raised concerns among some
Democrats that because of the power of
incumbency that if she did choose to run
again it could get very messy and
complicated but none of that is going to
happen because 89 year old Dianne
Feinstein says this is going to be it
for her now when you look at the names
of folks that are currently running here
there are a lot of different names some
we recognize for example Katie Porter
uh Adam Schiff
Barbara Lee actually Barbara Lee is not
on this list I thought hold on a second
Barbara Lee
senate race
Lee is planning to launch but has not
yet announced okay there is also a guy
named Barack Obama Mandela who's running
this is not in the Democratic side
remember that in California it is I
believe they call it a jungle primary
where everybody's on the same ballot and
the top two vote Getters make it to the
final election in in November of 2024.
so this is a large list of folks here
because of the political Dynamics in
California very blue State the senate
election in Practical terms is the
primary uh and it becomes clear from the
primary who is ultimately going to be
the senator and Katie Porter versus Adam
Schiff is going to be very interesting
if indeed Barbara Lee announces that she
is running and she's expected to in a
few days this is going to be a primary
with numerous Democratic Heavy Hitters
and I am not taking a position on it at
this time I genuinely don't know what to
expect from such a primary uh Adam
Schiff Barbara Lee and Katie Porter
all three relatively well known shift
probably the best known although Katie
Porter's social media presence is
significant a lot of viral moments she's
very very good in hearings so that's
going to be an interesting primary for
sure it is a good thing it is a good
thing that Dianne Feinstein has said
I've had a great run and she has longest
serving Senator oldest Senator and it
will be very interesting to see the
direction that California voters want to
see their representation go so we will
be certainly covering that race
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below